[Música]
este edificio residencial acaba de ser
alcanzado por un misil
su fachada está devastada
conseguimos escapar tuvimos suerte
porque estábamos en la cocina cuando la
primera bomba impactó en la entrada mi
esposa y mi hijo mayor tenían las
piernas rotas mi hijo menor fue llevado
a algún lugar por el equipo de rescate
no estoy buscando en varias partes de la
capital se han presentado disparos de
misiles y combates todavía no hay tropas
regulares rusas pero el ejército
ucraniano dice haber repelido un ataque
a una de las principales arterias de la
ciudad
el presidente ucraniano hizo un nuevo
llamado a la movilización
y trabajo estamos resistiendo con éxito
pero los enfrentamientos continúan en
todo el país estamos luchando para
proteger nuestra tierra y el futuro de
nuestros hijos mantenemos el control de
kiev y de puntos estratégicos alrededor
de la ciudad mientras los atacantes
intentan apoderarse de nuestro país
los rusos están concentrando sus ataques
en kiev al norte del país y en harkov
más al sur pero también han golpeado
otras ciudades en kiev tras el asalto
nocturno de las fuerzas rusas los
residentes se preparan para lo peor
desde esta mañana este hombre está
cavando una zanja en medio de una
carretera en la capital las calles están
desiertas mientras familias enteras se
refugian en los sótanos de los edificios
residenciales para los que han decidido
marcharse el éxodo continúa decenas de
miles de personas ya han sido
desplazadas